[Musique]
Eh bien, nous ne savons toujours pas ce qui va se passer.
passer
[Musique]
au moins il faut monter
maintenant mais plus tard nous ne savons pas comment
nous allons faire parce que nous ne sommes pas
Nous ne produisons pas autant
les dépenses à l'extérieur ont été réduites car
nous ne sortons pas dehors
[Musique]
essayer d'économiser autant que je peux
l'argent surtout pour le loyer
vil de la maison comme la lumière le câble le
de la nourriture et des trucs parce que ce n'est pas facile
Lorsque vous travaillez simplement sur le
à la maison avant qu'on soit trois maintenant c'est moi seul
[Musique]
pas le même que chaque table
de rien bonne journée les amis
et un d'ici il y a des mois
[Musique]